thank you to our sponsor rocket money do
you know how much your subscriptions
cost most Americans think they spend
around 80 a month on subscriptions when
the actual total is closer to two
hundred dollars if you don't know
exactly how much you're spending every
month you need rocket money stop
throwing your money away cancel unwanted
subscriptions and manage your expenses
the easy way by going to rocketmoney.com
trash Tuesday that's rocketmoney.com
trash Tuesday rocketmoney.com trash
Tuesday this show is sponsored by
betterhelp if you're thinking of
starting therapy give better help a try
it's entirely online designed to be
convenient flexible and suited to your
schedule visit betterhelp.com trash
Tuesday today to get 10 off your first
month that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash trash Tuesday whether
you're new to cannabis or an Old Pro
there's no denying that many of the
products on the market seem iffy at best
and when you want to relax iffy is the
last way you want to feel order your THC
products from mood today and for twenty
percent off your first order in free
gummies go to hellomood.com and use
promo code trash Tuesday that's
hellomood.com promo code trash Tuesday
for 20 off your order and free gummies
liquid death's new Iced Teas are
available now with free shipping on
Amazon and at retailers near you trash
Tuesday listeners get 20 off your first
liquid death apparel purchase available
exclusively at liquiddeath.com trash
that's liquiddeath.com trash for twenty
percent off their one-of-a-kind apparel
Miami I am coming to do stand-up April
21st and 22nd get tickets at
estronice.com and as always I have a
solo podcast you can check it out
wherever you listen to your podcast it's
Audio Only and it's super weird
hi sluggies I'm having the best time on
the road on the welcome to Annie wood
tour you can see me in Seattle this
March 10th and 11th you can see me in
Tampa March 17th and 18th in Toronto
April 21st and 22nd Riley North Carolina
May 12th and 13th I'll be in Salt Lake
City in June I will also be in Calgary
in August all these shows are going to
sell out there's also so many more
tickets coming and other shows so please
go to annieleterman.com shows and then
come see me every Thursday see my little
baby Annie wood my favorite little thing
my solo podcast that's on YouTube
um comment subscribe like it all that
stuff can't wait to see you
the last time that you were here you
talked about your dogs like the way that
it spoke to me oh I knew I understood
you yes they're your babies they're your
life that's my child your child yes and
you're the same way are you you seem
like a I'm co-parenting right now yeah
and you know what I I'm strict with a
co-parenting bobby came over yesterday
and he spent
um I don't know if we should be there
should be like a police escort outside
you know Hollywood co-parenting meetings
go
um but he cried on his way out oh sad he
was really really upset so upset that he
left his keys at my house his actual car
keys and I don't know how he got home I
woke up this morning I was like his keys
are here this is he outside is his car
gone his car is gone because he's in New
York that happened to me once where I
drove my car somewhere and I had to
valet and the valley is like where's the
keys and I'm like I literally don't have
them I don't know how I got here and
then I realized that this the whole time
ever since I had bought my car my extra
set of keys was in the car oh I never so
someone and I never knew why I couldn't
lock my car so there was always my car
was always unlocked and available to be
stolen for a year oh you lucked out can
you drive like a certain I don't know
like 50 I think so yeah I think that um
it won't stop but it's like shouldn't he
have kept his he would have had to keep
his engine on yeah that's weird I don't
know you never know what he's doing can
I ask like what can you tell us like the
rules of the dog custody or is that
personal
um well he asked initially that I take
all the animals not because he doesn't
want to be with him but he doesn't think
he's a good father
and I agreed
um I agree as well their basic needs
right but I'm like look I'm probably
gonna have to get a much smaller place
than this Fortress of a home so
um how about I take the four dogs and
you take the cats because cats are easy
you can just put you know yeah and he
agreed to that but then the new
agreement is now I have to go back and
forth and take care of the cats as well
oh wow oh no so he his thing was you
cannot live more than like eight minutes
away
because this cold parenting thing really
is single parenting yeah so that's the
that's the vibe and also the cats have a
catio because we built this whole little
like jungle Palace for them okay so I'm
like they have to stay there yeah that's
cute that's cool cats around but would
you guys I have a question for you guys
wait should we introduce to guests first
sure
um okay do you want me to do it yeah I
do you guys I've been really excited for
this Duo to come on this show only
because I truly think Beyond just being
funny girls their True Performance
artists everyone Chelsea Lynn paigekin
I've been such huge fans for a very long
time thank you honey and you guys are
fellow wild and crazy female podcasters
oh big time yeah yeah we're wild they
have their own podcast called viral
podcast yeah we're trying to take over
the world the Vara podcast and we are
trying to take over the world I always
say that well I think that you have to
have that big of a goal at all times
that's how I feel like I'm going for the
top I'm not like yes world domination I
think Madonna said that she wanted that
and look where she landed exactly I love
that yeah I think that I I told this to
a friend yesterday I was like wait a
second like everyone always says to like
temper your dreams or manage your
expectations of life and I'm like no
like delusion has gotten me pretty far
and this idea of being like grandiose
I'm like wait I can do that like it's
good to be cocky and audacious I'm
leaning into that for sure I'm like I
used to have to really be like shy and
and hide how confident I don't know if
confidence is the right word because I
think it's all is wrapped in insecurity
and low self-worth but
um I feel like I've had to how much I
love myself I've had to hide because
that can be very off-putting to men yeah
and so now I'm like no I'm better than
you guys and not only men so many people
are that will put you down for if you
dream big they're like you can't do that
you know so it's like why do you even
it's hard to express yourself if people
aren't accepting it you know sometimes
it's almost like you just gotta keep
keep the dream quiet but keep it big in
yourself oh yeah also the reason why I
think it's good for the world to lean
into that kind of confidence is we are
publicly showing it to other people and
they will learn and be love themselves
more through it all yes for good reason
yeah spread the love
who's this
hey honey came in with the faction
hello hello
that's Paige nice to meet you hi little
Munch oh my goodness hi little one I
wanted it I wanted to ask you guys like
suppose you were single and you met a
perfect guy and he ticks all the boxes
but then he meets your dogs for the
first time and he's not it's not that
he's mean he just doesn't give him the
same mouth kissy love that you give he's
kind of like indifferent
oh that'd be hard if he was mean and
didn't like done of course if he could
if he liked them but just wasn't as
obsessed with him I think I could deal
with but what if what if he's like
they're just dogs oh one time we were
interviewing roommates my husband and I
and we had this guy walk in and he
literally walked in until he was barking
because a stranger had walked in the
door and the guy as soon as he walks in
goes uh is she gonna do this a lot
and I go where yeah you're just getting
invited into my house we're done yeah
I'm actually wondering how you feel
about how far donut just went up my nose
that's okay because you're like us you
know you're saying well she's now high
on Academy
oh my God it would be left over from a
while ago but I mean it was up that far
you're taller than I I'm shocked I'm a
big [__] I'm excited about I didn't
even stand up
I feel like Esther I'm huge wait how
tall are you five eleven
wow five eleven oh that's my dad's
height maybe that's why
I love you Daddy the perfect little yes
I'll tell her she's a dumb [__]
I'm five eight my sister is six feet
tall wow but you know you live with
someone long enough and you just don't
think they're tall and then you don't
see him for a while and you're like wait
we're related every time I see Astra I
feel the opposite way and donut actually
I feel the same way about you and Jordan
I'm like how are you guys real oh is
this a thing it's still I'm taking
advantage of it you still feel what the
nose she got up in there oh Donut's goal
in life is to eat your brain through
your nose I feel like because her tongue
is small enough that it can go so far
I'm feeling less bad memories she got my
Sheila bottle what have you done uh like
nothing no mushrooms just like this oh I
do smoke or I do smoke weed and do
mushrooms I like the idea of smoking
mushrooms yeah yeah I would try it but
I've never done cocaine nothing same me
neither of the nosy me neither
ketamine for like like to get me out of
my depression oh you have like nose you
have have like nostril issues of someone
who did do a lot of code you like got
like a collapsed I have a collapsed
valve and but I've never done cocaine it
kind of just did it this valve is good
to go though this valve is oh yeah
actually yes it's better hey because
what's healed what happened with that uh
Instagram guy remember last time I was
here oh you know I never followed up
because he it was too much he he was
doing what I'm talking about oh yeah
yeah so
yini yeah yes very hot very wonderful
and he came back with hey like honestly
like this game has got to end let me
take you out to dinner like what's the
what's the hold up and then I I got
scared and then I asked out kind of an
ick I I didn't reply but not because I
didn't appreciate it
are you upset
what happened a little bit there's a
porn a porn boy a porn guy his whole
thing is like he's a pleasure Dom and
he's extremely good looking and I talked
about him once in the podcast and
basically he was like what's up like so
basically this whole thing is like he
just wants to make girls come over and
over and over again what a guy I know
that's what I'm saying I know I am I
know you left him on red I did and I I
do feel like I just didn't have a good
like reply because I I don't think I am
open to go to dinner I can't do it you
not a dinner [__] maybe also maybe
you're not feeling deserving of the
multiple orgasm that you know you're
gonna get wait maybe you're not feeling
deserving of being dominated with
pleasure
think about it I actually love love
coming like over and over again no to
the point where it hurts yeah
but I love the comfort of making myself
come over and over again like the idea
that there is like an extra work in the
room that may I say something that may
not be how you feel but I now feeling
how I would feel if I was being asked
these questions
making yourself come you're alone you're
gonna a pleasure dumb he's dominating
beyond your own like ability to maintain
some sort of cuteness in your pleasure
so it is like so vulnerable if you get
to that fourth fifth right and it is out
of my control and he's just now he's
seeing that's what he's probably getting
off on is seeing the whole I'm like no I
don't want to come anymore I'm depleted
I'm out and he just keeps going and
that's what you know what you're only at
like three percent at that point oh yeah
when you're saying that you're like no
no see none of that is what bothers me
it's just that he asked you to dinner is
what's grossing me for some reason like
there's something about that like I
don't like like you know where he's
gonna be he's like like his fingers
I don't know I'm like there's something
about being asked out on a date I don't
think I've ever that's ever worked for
me so it just feels like it happened no
would just one come yeah I'm just good
with one one a day or one I don't want
to be too [__] or I notice you guys
bleep out your cuss words so I'm gonna
try not the only first 10 minutes oh we
don't I think we're good right okay yeah
yeah the whole podcast would be like no
me too they keep taking our money away
as well yeah they don't like giving it
out but yeah one one nut because if I
get numb and if he's trying to force a
nut on the numbness it might do
something but I like when I'm when I'm
getting at myself I like to just you try
to push through the numbness how far can
I go wait how numb are we talking like
um below like the legs are paralyzed
stranger like you know the boys that sit
on their hands and their hand goes numb
I'm talking the girl version where you
just go so hard it goes numb and then
you're like who am I fingering it's like
is it me is it a stranger oh my God you
and I are we're pretty close like you've
been pretty vulnerable with me I feel
like it would make perfect sense if you
mutually masturbate were to allow me to
watch you masturbate would you really
answer can I just tell you daveing out
out of town like now look at this is
this a surprise Esther's now like let me
see inside the outside I'd like to see
the inside my tongue but would you Annie
I think you I think you respect me a
little enough that you would let me
watch if I let you if I it would be a
complete disrespect if I let you watch
I'd be like this is how little I respect
no that's what I'm saying no
um probably not what what about like if
you were honestly I think completely
honest
substance
any ecstasy maybe ecstasy maybe acid
acids made me very horny at times don't
you think it's good for like group
bonding for like if you guys for example
you host a podcast together to just like
get high in ecstasy and group masturbate
yeah
try it for 30 days
completely forget about a subscription
or service I always get conned into this
I swear I always forget that I've
subscribed to something and I rack all
of these unnecessary costs up and I
swear to you rocket money has saved my
life
do you understand that I have been doing
this exact mistake probably since I was
like 15 where like you sign up for
something you think you're getting oh a
deal it's free and then suddenly like
you forget about it it's 10 years later
you're still paying you're homeless your
whole life is in shambles your teeth are
loose or like what's going on here well
the average person has around 12 paid
subscriptions you need to think about
that for a second like if you're only
subscribed to a handful of services if
that's what you think you may want to
double check and here's the thing you
get that money back you you cancel and
get that money back you get to spend it
on things like skims rocket money
formerly known as true bill is a
personal finance app that finds and
cancels your unwanted subscriptions
monitors your spending and helps you
lower your bills all in one place over
80 percent of people have subscriptions
that they forgot about like that
streaming service you bought to watch
just one show on or that free trial that
you never even used that's me for sure
and Rocket money will quickly can easily
identify your subscriptions for you so
you can stop paying for the ones that
you don't want and over 3 million people
have used rocket money saving the
average person up to 720 dollars a year
stop throwing your money away cancel
unwanted subscriptions and manage your
expenses the easy way by going to
rocketmoney.com trash Tuesday that's
rocketmoney.com trash Tuesday
rocketmoney.com trash Tuesday this show
is sponsored by betterhelp you guys
getting to know yourself can be a
lifelong process especially because
we're always growing and changing and
therapy is all about deepening your
self-awareness and understanding because
sometimes we don't know what we want or
why we or why we react the way we do
until we talk through things better help
connects you with a licensed therapist
who can take you on that journey of
self-discovery from wherever you are
that is the most important thing about
therapy to me is the self-discovery like
there's so much in there and it's not no
and it's not good it's not good
the more I know the more tools I have to
figure out why that's happening the
spinnies the scaries all of the S words
they're all in there
and if you're engine geese the it wasn't
that a thing we talked about the
jingies yeah the Django when you just
can't stop thinking about that movie
honestly yes you guys if you're thinking
of starting therapy give better help a
try it's entirely online it's designed
to be convenient flexible and suited to
your schedule
just fill out a brief questionnaire to
get matched with a licensed therapist
and switch therapist anytime for no
additional charge this show has been con
considered uh it's been called a therapy
session but it's not it's really not
okay guys actually unprofessional
because to say that it's foreplay to
therapy we're not therapists okay we
need therapy badly discover your
potential with better help visit
betterhelp.com trash Tuesday today to
get 10 off your first month that's
better help
h-e-l-p.com slash trash Tuesday
[Music]
like masturbate with the neighbors type
kid growing up oh God my mom was yeah
we're like your Kitty's on the corner oh
yeah yeah the chair 100 I was always
humping my grandma's chair yes and she
would hump her doll's head oh yeah I
think you told us this I would [__] my
dolls oh yeah yeah and what would you
like were you like with the neighborhood
kids doing it too like we would steal
our parents porns and watch them like
bring all the neighbors over and we
would like lock the door and we'd all
wait so why is it okay that in middle
school we do that right well I didn't
but I said one brother
I saw it
but it's like you always hear stories
about like yeah like the boys stole
their parents porn and there's eight of
them around and they're just like you
know quietly jerking off like what
happened to that as adults like did we
just abandon like that past time we
didn't masturbate though it was like the
whole neighborhood would come over and
we would just watch them and be like hey
this is weird nope
but I don't think I have that experience
of like open did you masturbate in front
of neighbors no no we would hump as
little kids yeah through our clothes
just hump I know it's just so weird that
you're like this thing feels good I know
yeah that was weird so you don't look
like you're you've ever humped no I did
not have any sexual no not me you never
lean forward in a chance
I never had that neighborhood kids
neighborhood boys you never just humps
girls honestly no I I I don't know what
that means about me you all did that
yeah because if you if you felt pressure
like the first time like I really rode a
bike like I felt the pressure against my
[__] I was like oh this feels nice
because I want a couple bike rides
although she doesn't know how to ride a
bike that's why I feel that's why sex is
like riding a bike Esther doesn't matter
Esther's really bad at it they never
make bike seats that just rub your [__]
and it gets um faster the more you pedal
we're all just pedaling around
just on our chairs for us I'm always
like did you just throw this into a poor
new monster we're gonna do those you
know those bouncy balls with the winners
we're literally gonna film a pod where
we're sitting on those
we don't know if it will be inserted or
islands are hanging out in the back yeah
kind of keeping you on and yeah we won't
say much you know we're not going to say
much we're going to tell people what
we're sitting on we're going to do the
pods the whole time with it in us
they're pretty girthy
um see we'll see we'll see how girthy
they are yeah I want to ask you guys a
question I know you guys have sent
pictures of your vaginas to each other's
fathers yeah um but I didn't send her
dad one no you didn't just just yeah her
dad no why why wasn't it reciprocated oh
I don't talk to my dad
we wanted to know the response yeah he
didn't respond
um we later come to find out that he
didn't respond because he thought it was
a fan of ours and he didn't want to get
in trouble because people message him
and get his phone number all the time
and people try to [__] him and her dad's
like 75 77 77 like and he's still
[__] right yep I'm thinking so oh
yeah he is and people try to [__] him
all the time so he was like Austin Annie
he's a Chinese man yeah okay you're a
dad yeah and he has a big dick because
well
because it got caught in the zipper I
don't know if you heard but he we
couldn't get it out oh my God
she had to touch it yeah I was like oh
funny and people thought that video was
fake and it was not no well for a second
I think oh should we pull up the video
This is actually a really cute like
Family Video I think I I thought my dad
had a heart attack because my brother
came out Paige we have a serious problem
I Dad Dad zipped up his dick oh my God
it was bad when I first saw it I didn't
realize that you were um half Chinese so
I was like what is Paige doing with us
with this Chinese man dick in her house
you can't see other houses
that's the other half asian well no and
not with her so much I think I don't
know why but in the same people can't
see it with me no since I met you and
since I started dating Todd I call ever
I would be like are you Asian like I
can't tell you how many white people I'm
like are you Asian like what no one's
ever said that to me in my life I just
assume Asian first Maybe
yeah very small and smart yeah oh there
you go here we go
and then you're Asian
but didn't we establish that your
general Vibe is that of like a middle
school like Japanese boy yes thank you
no I have I really respect and adore the
Asian culture paper shoes is that a
thing I don't know to see you in them do
you do like the Rubik's Cube
um I never you know what I gave up early
on the Rubik's Cube that was a struggle
for me I was not good at it right out
the gate she gave it 120 one twist
I can't figure that one out the Rubik's
Cube well here's the thing with the
Rubik's Cube you know that you can just
look online and know forever but it's
like did you guys know only really I
liked Obi
I thought that was a tampon brand a
hobby drink this is a Rubik's Cube for
idiots damn it's a squeeze yeah you just
it's just a tampon it's not coming no
there's no Cube I pretty much just
messed with bop it if I'm the only one
yeah
kind of reminding me of your thing
what's that Esther Esther you discovered
something very cute oh yeah I'm like
making something up a fat wiener dog so
wait sorry can we pull up Paige's video
with her daddy I think this is really
cool oh it's on Instagram
that was a stress ball that was given to
you no I know you squeeze it and the
eyes pop out that's all it does oh yeah
it's um for coping yeah puzzle figure
this out
[Music]
[Laughter]
I couldn't stop [__] and riding bikes
and Esther's like is this a puzzle
squeeze in it
okay it should be down
okay stop oh my God right there
can you imagine here he is
hot daddy
oh that's my brother trying to help him
there's me trying to think
dude that was like a real thinking
stance too you could tell this isn't
staged
what are you handing them or vitamin E
oh that's so cute yeah your dad's a
hobby wait your dad is really cute oh he
might get at you
so watch what you say I'm into the Asian
persuasion
he'll be happy to hear for real yeah
when I was in there it wasn't his balls
it was his shaft
I don't care who's having the problem
it's the taskrabbit did you get my
ex-boyfriend on test rabbit once I saw
him on there yeah wait Paige were you
the hero here yeah you were the person
who finally got it out yeah my brother's
like we got to go to the hospital and
was he okay with filming it were you
like look we gotta do this he I don't
even think he noticed because he was in
so much pain yeah he couldn't even walk
so I'm like we cannot get like we cannot
spend more time trying to go to the
hospital he probably would have lost it
if the camera on it's not hold on Dad
hold on Dad we gotta film
you didn't get that on film it would
have been an absolute National tragedy
nobody would ever known right would you
guys save
uh anybody in your family yeah oh yeah
well my dad was bedridden the last
couple years of his life and so my mom
my sister and I were basically his
caretakers so like I ended up having to
like wipe my dad's ass like there were
times where I would sit him up and he's
like I'm sitting on my balls and I'd be
like oh sorry you know because it it
gets pretty far back there that's like a
good wrap but
but I think what I wanted to ask you
guys is like do you have
have you ever seen your dad's penis and
is it okay this is what we're talking
about
so her line is so weird okay they sent
their [__] to their dads did you not
think
right and you're asking all so serious I
know I did squishy balls I thought it
was gonna be like your dad said
something serious stop it Annie um my
question in all like I know your dad
would like it I'm being serious it's
like for me the first time I saw my
dad's penis was when I had to take care
of him and there was a moment when I
changed his diapers where I was like
oh he's he's done well in life like he's
got a you know his size is good like is
that a bad thing for me to have clocked
in my head well you're older at this
time you've seen other penises usually
people see their dad's penises on
accident when they're kids so you don't
have a range I have a joke about this
about how I remember my dad's dick being
big and he's like no it's small and I'm
like what was like was I looking I was
like Magnolia he's a big dick you know
yeah but um I have a long bed you have
to come see me live
um but I you know I've seen my dad's I
used to my joke was always like it's not
Christmas till he's seen your dad's dead
because my dad Wears Like nightgowns
my Dad wears like I love it yeah I'm
like he'll wear the one that you get
like at Christmas like it'll it's
they've got like scallop like a scoop
and then it says Coca-Cola it comes with
a hat but it doesn't wear the hat I love
him he wears nightgowns and then they
have this awning upstairs so I'll come
in like guys I'm home you know my dad
would be like Annie's home and I'm like
oh my God I'm underwear
Devil's eye view of these balls yeah
gosh so yeah I've seen my dad stick
quite a bit but I don't think it's bad
to clock this up yeah I I yeah if you
didn't okay yes it's the most important
penis in your life yeah well I always
think of it as this like if I ever have
a son and his dick is small it will not
be my from my side of the family yes
that's on his dad I've seen all my
uncles and they're well you know they're
girthy mothers oh this is where we get I
was about to say yeah what's going on
there we go okay yeah where'd you see
those no
a lot of them a lot of them would like
swing their dicks around like after the
shower I know it's a molesty family but
um yeah I wish I hadn't seen it but I
saw it growing up and they were like oh
okay
just doing the helicopter of this
concept that's like pretty it's more
common than you think but we're two
brothers
one has a really big dick and one has a
small dick and it like basically like
[__] up there a lot both of their lives
their relationship with each other yeah
I've heard didn't we have someone on our
show who said no it was someone I know
was telling me about her sons and then I
was talking about it with some guys and
they're like yeah we have guy friends
who like one brother they know both
brothers and one had a small dick and
one had a big dick and it's like it the
difference in their lives was like wow
really severe
that's so interesting though like do
does it does it affect their
relationship with each other because I'm
sure they've seen each other yeah is
there a result
a bald brother and a full head of hair
brother it was like ooh
well and also like
um
you would assume that brothers would all
have the same similar size but that's
not the case at all that's what was
surprising I would think that
that they would all have the same yeah
yeah not not necessarily because I've
seen my sister's [__] and it couldn't
be more different than mine hers is like
a porn star damn like very everything is
just so put together and a different
color that is like wow like you you are
like she's a Barbie doll she's a yeah
she is and then I always look at mine
like how like should I get it like at
your height yeah putting nuts look at
that [__] in my face all day I saw my
grandma's [__] I've never seen an uncle
or a dad's dick but I did see my
grandma's [__] spread open when she was
in the hospital she was getting out of
her out of the bed in a hospital gown I
was helping her out she flipped open her
legs it was right there and I was
shocked it was beautiful you wouldn't
think a 75 year old woman's [__] but I
kind of I kind of stopped him I was like
nanny
I go you have a pretty vagina and she
was like I know like I know how do you
think you got here gosh I was like wow
um I always thought there would be
cheese oh and an older cheese lots of
just meat hanging no her [__] was tight
no wrinkle nothing it looked like you
know a 20 year old's [__] I was like
wow
[Music]
I haven't seen my grandmas yet you gotta
ask to look at it my grandma's Daddy
she's our resident Gravedigger let me
see that we do have like a Gravedigger
here no also yesterday one of my friends
was like she's a groundskeeper he was
like how is anyone a mortician and my
reaction was like I would kill it at
being a mortician it's like literally
playing dress-up with a smell bad no
they don't and that wouldn't bother me
and their human smells it's like playing
dress-up where you have all the control
and I don't think that's scary and then
my friend was like well aren't you
scared of dead bodies I'm like that's
the least scary thing is there's the
body what's the most scary then someone
with like a weapon who wants to hurt you
a dead body is not scary do you guys
feel like you could be a magician yeah
but have you ever heard of a death
rattle no a death rattle is basically
like rest in peace this is pretty tragic
but what happened to Anne Heche where
you think they're dead and then all of a
sudden they have one more blast of like
adrenaline and they like kind of spring
up and you just spread your legs that's
a pretty boost
that's exciting that doesn't sound I'm I
just appeared on a call [__] on this
are you really a groundskeeper you don't
lie are you really I'm confusing if like
a bug is near bugs are different I'm
grossed out by bugs dead bodies so bad
and it's not a regular human smell that
you're smelling also bugs can bite you
and kill you like we have instincts to
be afraid of them a dead body cannot
hurt I don't want to tell you about this
new show on uh HBO or on uh what's the
last of us there's a show oh the yeah
they give those dead people can bite you
oh I haven't watched that yet but that's
a show Annie he may never have the
Soul's flying around the Demonic [__]
that scares me
with the body same yeah I I'm really
scared of but Esther doesn't get her
around the corpse because I gotta see I
wanna great let's go to uh forensic
scientist school or something no let's
go to the Body Farm in Indiana
basically where I think I think it's in
the Indiana where they take like Jane
Doe's and John does and they're like I
don't know how this person died so they
send it over to these forensic
entomologists who basically use insects
to date a dead body how long has this
body been dead and they're able to like
identify like the cause of death and um
it's just a body Farm they have
volunteers they're allowed to go or
we're allowed I mean like a museum we're
not volunteers Esther does have a good
point though because I think you're just
out at Hobby Lobby walking next to like
an effort Dahmer or you know yeah
there's way creepier people I'd rather
be like a Jeffrey Dahmer in the room
than not yeah you know yeah that's so
sad we're trying her little body trying
to chop up a big person oh
Esther with the saw it's like a big body
when you guys are out and about do you
look for exit signs or are you not that
paranoid always I have a list of people
I call my active Shooters and uh
socially enough it's social I know we
wouldn't be here
on my look I look for the exit I'm
always like
okay I'm out here not that I'm scared of
them I just don't want to talk to them
well they're yeah it's not my vibes you
know and you're like oh just in case I'm
an exit marker because my mom like my
whole life would always like tell us
horror stories about like clubs getting
like um catching on fire like like dance
clubs he's like see if you go to a dance
club look at 386 young people dead
because there was a fire at a warehouse
a club so like my whole life it's like
you're going to the club you might die
of a fire so she's always like Mark your
exits everywhere wait your mom would say
that to you yeah okay I wonder is that
why you think you're more of like a
homebody because I have this too where
my mom was such a worrier and would
every time I would do something she'd be
like well be careful of this you know
and put all this fear into you and then
that's why like every time you leave the
house you're like is it worth the risk
do you feel that
um no because I've definitely been been
a club hoe for you know a couple years
in Vegas we saw that outfit thank you
don't forget that side pony [__] what
were you doing your [__] was hanging
out I used to live in Vegas for a couple
of years so I definitely did my rounds
is just you know you just see your
typical happy ho in Vegas
and
it's like you just were in a
relationship that
bro that was more domestic and I don't
know I think this is why I wear Crocs
every day I think those days are over
but what do you guys do you have any
tips for a girl like me who's like just
gotten out of a 10-year relationship
damn maybe just figuring out who you are
as a human and you know just spend some
time by yourself honestly yeah and don't
leave Dom's on red
after dogs yeah I just wanted to find
out how that went me too like does he
just eat your [__]
is he gonna have intercourse should we
try to just calling yeah just cold
calling him well we'll do it at the end
of the show yeah he doesn't pick up it's
over oh my gosh we gotta call him
it's actually never over the pleasure
Dom I think
he's waiting on you he is waiting
anybody who has gone to him
um I don't but I have seen some of his
stuff and he really is like a great you
could tell he's a good lover
like he knows what if you're like
there's something about him coming in
I'm the good lover where I'd be like
you're the good lover you know but I
guess he must be used to that and be
able to penetrate through yeah and his
Dick's like kind of pretty just imagine
you're like you know what I want to [__]
a lot of [__] I'm just gonna say the
unpleasured Dom yeah that's how you do
it yeah yeah he's gaslighting you guys
for sure
I remember going just going out to eat
like after there was this guy who I used
to bump cigarettes from and I I found
him to be so annoying but I I just I'm
seriously
and it was just like all right he was
like do you want to get food I'm like
sure so we go out to a diner after and
it's like I don't want to be hanging out
with him there's no sexual anything
there's nothing like that he's like an
open micros like a 45 year old [__]
first day it was just he was the most
annoying person
we're gonna eat he just starts talking
about how he can make women come 13
times I had this I'd go clap in his face
and be like we're done here like I don't
first of all don't believe you second of
all not interested don't even want to
imagine you [__] anyone is this
yeah it's a person you'll never know
it's a person you'll never hear about
for sure 100 that's something you should
just never do yeah just go on a date and
talk about somebody else or you know
that's already a red flag yeah don't do
that that's annoying wait so
um when we did
um tigerbelly
um you guys talked about getting your
stuff yanked off of Instagram
often and even if it's not like a fully
nude thing
um we see a lot of people on there just
good looking people like full tits out
nipples out and they their stuff stays
up there for example Paige you did a
side by side you did exact replica of
Kendall Jenner's post and they took
yours down they kept hers yeah and
um I just wanna I had a thought on my
way over here where it's like you know
if you were to count or make an appeal
you could technically say like what you
do the falling the stuff that they
consider like why island or whatever it
is performance art that is what you do
and it's like is there a way to appeal
it in that way that's what I've tried to
do like even if I have to put I'm not uh
you know don't try this at home to other
people maybe that would keep it up but I
don't know they'd take down all my fall
videos
because I'm putting others in danger and
scaring old people with my Falls like
distress so I don't know but with the
whole nudity thing I don't know why that
gets taken down maybe they just change
it though didn't they just make it so
you can put your tits on Instagram what
not me well it hurts just got taken down
and it was the exact same thing and also
it's like how boring is [__] hell
boring and then also there's nowhere to
cut like it's not like you can try to
get to Instagram but they make it just
so hard yeah I wouldn't care if ever the
rules applied for everybody but it's so
unfair yeah and the double standard yeah
so infuriating too
breast hugging cupping and holding to be
shown in posts I had um I was from 2020
anyway I had a um oh I see that's
another idea I had I had
um the things that have gotten flagged
in my thing that have really [__] with
my algorithm and my business which is so
annoying is
Whitney Cummings posted something and I
reposted it and wrote duh [__] with a
heart
flagged like my business is now in
Jeopardy because I wrote that then and I
wrote back and I was that's all then I
did I was doing a gig at a casino and it
was like
there were these like Tumbleweed weird
gross creepy
just like area outside of the casino and
I did a promo there where I was like Hey
guys either see me tonight or you can
see my special on Dateline when I'm
murdered
my I now am literally my my reach is now
like shrunk oh yeah because of those two
things and it's like are you guys
[__] kidding well her whole thing got
taken down my whole Instagram for no
reason at a million followers they just
taken down
no they took it down had over a million
followers and she even asked like why or
like can we talk to the people who
decided and they're like no no I just
started to say yeah serious it's been
almost a year ago and Instagram said
um they told my management they were
like well you know we're not giving her
her page back but here's the link to the
community guidelines have her read it
but I would have stuff taken down that
were like
like a selfie would get taken down I was
cooking eggs one day and it got done for
sexual well this is why I'm thinking
that Instagram favors what they consider
um good looking people to portray
themselves in a I don't think the same
thing happened with Bobby like he he put
a picture of him naked but there was and
I edited the photo myself full coverage
like I put a Emoji over his deck
um I think in like only a couple weeks
later there was a picture of Stevo full
everything out with his girlfriend like
super like sexual and that God didn't
get taken down but Bobby's did almost
instantly Eric Andre's Valentine's Day
post oh with Emily
did it stay up launch yeah it's yeah
it's still up even it's covered but he's
shown her but she's naked in the back
and then she was saying that Bobby's was
covered Bobby's was completely and then
also Eric has posted his full deck on
Instagram he has I don't know how long
it stayed
Tommy Lee Tommy Lee yeah I mean that
stayed up for probably like way longer
than it should have I guess so I just
have this theory that who they find
attractive stays up you know what if you
had that theory there's a really good
chance that it's true because look at
how we keep finding these things out
like even Tick Tock has gotten like it's
come out that they push things through
their algorithm that like the employees
like so I think all this stuff nothing
is fair like right oh no it's so it's
like if we suspect that it's probably
true right what do we do though we just
be ourselves
is the truth app or whatever it's called
yeah I'm getting on parlor I told
everyone I said I'll see you on parlor
oh it hits parlor I said I've had enough
quiet at home alone it's annoying and it
gets in the way of like content and
comedy like I'll do like skits or you
know not even just pictures just like
you know comedy and they'll take it down
um you know when I first started years
ago eight nine years ago people now are
like oh your your videos are so
different than they were I missed those
video I missed the things you used to do
I'm like I can't post that [__] I don't
even wouldn't have a place to post yeah
right they put you in a creative block
yeah yes you can't truly just be
yourself
I got one too where I like I was holding
a pill bottle and there was no you
couldn't see what it was that got
flagged too oh my you don't know what is
this it's just it's to me you can't
swear
like when you said [__] that they
probably flagged that I think the last
thing that got taken down of mine was
like a Mother's Day post where I said
like happy Mother's Day or wish your
mother's like a Happy Mother's Day and
it was a picture of me like cupping
Bobby's butt but he wasn't even naked it
was just a tiny bit of his tattoo on his
butt showing and it was just my hands
down his pants but his ass wasn't
showing I'm like this is [__] but
also people isn't it people reporting it
too yeah I don't I think it's more
Instagram I think that they should be
the person who decides to take it down
they should be like shown you know
because it's so easy to make a decision
behind a computer I like Kylie Jenner
yeah you should be talking I'll be a
good girl and I will be a supportive and
healthy happy good pure girl for you
thank you for the like oh wow good pure
girl all your posts if you said
is that prettier than your grandmother's
[__]
taste test we do a banana break just as
uh
she's like if I get demonetized you get
D Minor yeah Annie what would you do if
you found out that Todd
secretly like me and he didn't even know
so it's Innocent but that he had a kid
that like came forward that would be
cool really yeah I'd be like oh cool we
have a kid I don't have to have or do
really that much for this is oh my
dreams have come true how long have
y'all been together
um like three and a half years maybe or
maybe three now okay I think it's three
because it was we kind of were together
on battleships because it was right
before covet and then he
um so is that four years or three years
three she's like me you're asking me I
when covid everyone's like I feel like
kova was just yesterday or whatever I'm
like no no I feel like when I see people
I've been seeing you in eight years
they're like I saw you three years ago
I'm like oh I'm like wow it's been a
decade damn would you how would you feel
if you found out your partner like had a
kid that if it came forward wait better
yet how about this Chelsea you and Greg
have been together for a while like 16
years yeah
let's say the kid is eight years old so
somewhere in the middle of their
relationship that's obviously come on
but no but it was eight years ago now oh
it don't matter yeah it's really dead oh
yeah yeah show us on the banana what you
do Don you said oh dude just [__]
damn I wanted that
damn
uh
yeah how long six years I think uh so
let's suppose the kid is five and a half
years old comes knocking at your door
and it's like hey like your your man is
my dad
I would say uh you're done yeah I'm not
if he didn't know because I mean
no I'm just I just don't want that right
yeah you know I don't want to be taking
care of a kid five five year olds is it
the kids the thing or the Betrayal of it
well I mean yeah and the cheating you
guys I'm like so Jonathan cheat I'm like
at this point I'm like if you cheat on
me oh it's a wrap if you if I can't
trust you and you lie to me once then
you're always gonna lie it's like I
don't know about cheaters and how single
girl how would you date a guy who has
kids
as somebody who just recently went on a
couple dates with someone with kids
I wasn't turned off by it only because
like I saw like what a great dad he was
but also like this is going to sound
terrible
he has daughters and like I really like
I can
I don't know like I I I'm good with
daughters and young girls and I feel
like it's very easy to click with them
so no I didn't feel any type of way
about it but I would have taken it much
slower than had it been a guy with no
kids like I would have really like what
about if it was a boy on like a snail's
pace
I would have been more worried I think
because I just like I don't have a lot
of experience like raising young boys I
have experience raising like my nieces
and I feel like I've done done a really
good job but I just would feel a lot
more like nervous about like Big Boy
energy I'm like I don't know what to do
with that but
um the snail space thing for sure
like if he had no kids we probably would
have been far progressed in our
relationship I think that makes sense
you have you kind of have to move slower
when someone has kids I don't know why
that like feels right to me because it
involves it's like a more serious
commitment because you're also like yes
becoming even if you're not like
obviously their parent you're like
co-parenting I was just talking to
someone today about how his stepson he
realized he was an uncle to him like he
had to give him Uncle energy because he
couldn't be what his father was I
thought that was cool I like that yeah
well and for the kids too who knows like
how much that guy's dating you don't
want to just keep bringing your kid
around these new people yeah yeah that
might mess up their head like one a year
like a teacher yeah yeah one thing one
each grade one a year yeah for sure
because I remember my dad like dating
people and I was like who the hell who
the hell is this did your mom and dad
separate yeah when I was eight and how
many are you the youngest yeah the
youngest so after you they separated but
all your brothers all your siblings are
all from the same mom
uh my dad had four and then four so yeah
so oh there's eight of you yeah wow cool
I love it that's like we're all we're
all really close like show each other
buttholes that's really like you know
fun to have that big of a family it's
fun it's a lot of fun yeah she's like
what the hell I had a friend I have a
friend that has a very large family and
she was and they're older they're in
their 50s and 60s now and they were
saying they were like it's interesting
throughout your life you become closer
to you've got like buddied up with each
at different times in your life have you
found that yeah we all have a different
relationship and in a good way yeah I
feel though that's why I mean Chelsea
get along because she's like a motherly
person and I always attach myself to
people who will like take care of me
yeah that's her that's very true we have
that type of relationship yeah
friendship yeah
whether you're new to cannabis or an Old
Pro I identify as both honestly there's
no denying that many of the products on
the market seem iffy at best and when
you want to relax if he is the last way
you want to feel mood puts an end to
guessing games it's 100 federally legal
Delta 8 and Delta 9 THC that you can
have shipped straight to you no doctors
no waiting it's just Affordable Legal
THC
and you guys there's something for every
move the experts at mood have tested and
tailored different strains for specific
moods energize for when you want to
seize the day creative to get inspired
and mentally stimulated or even focused
perfect for getting in the zone I have
to say for me with THC like I really
lean into the like direction of the
specific strain like I really will do a
relaxing one for sleepy time I will
creative like when I'm writing I will
take a creative strain and that just
helps me it really does like open up my
mind and stuff I really appreciate when
companies like are able to prescribe
what it can actually do for you other
moves they have are euphoric erotic
erotic you ever pop one of those up in
you are you kidding the gummies go in
here Esther going here however you like
to take THC mood has you covered great
for both beginner and Veteran users so
for me one of my favorite moods that I I
use with them is energized that's like
if I am doing it during the daytime and
I just you know want to feel like I'm
really going to be active that day I'll
maybe take one go for a walk stuff like
that creative is one that I'll sit down
even just like if I'm setting up to do
my email and like work stuff for the day
I'll throw a creative on it just puts me
in like a lighter happier mood what's
cool about it is they have all these
different gummies and stuff and you can
actually go into the website and you can
find the ones that are for if you want
energy you want it to be versatile it's
all categorized so it's easy yeah which
I really need that when I'm using THC
because
no because I don't want to just pick any
strain and not know like specifically
what I'm working towards in that moment
and the other moods that are my
favorites are euphoric erotic sleepy
chill social body Soother like honestly
not to be too TMI but erotic is like
very essential in my life
um and great tasting gummies classic
flower convenient pre-rolls and so much
more are you ready for a good time
without the guesswork order your THC
products from mood today and for 20 off
your first order and free gummies go to
hellomood.com and use promo code trash
Tuesday that's hello
m-o-o-d.com promo code trash Tuesday for
20 off your first order and free gummies
you guys here at trash Tuesday we're a
little bit addicted to liquid death and
the fact that they came out with three
flavors of iced tea it's just
it's like it's Christmas in a month that
we don't deserve Christmas okay now the
cans of iced tea are healthy unlike a
lot of other like other Iced Teas that
are loaded with sugar these are lightly
sweetened with six grams of Premium
Agave they're only 30 calories and
provide a micro dose of caffeine per
tall boy they're also enhanced with B
vitamins thank you we love that three
new flavors Grim Leaf fur rest in Peach
armless Palmer and you guys as always
liquid death has the cutest merch cute
pink sweaters skull tees liquid deaths
new Iced Teas are available now with
free shipping on Amazon and retailers
near you as an added bonus trash Tuesday
listeners get 20 off their first liquid
death apparel purchase available
exclusively at liquidath.com trash
exclusions May apply that's liquidat.com
trash
well this question probably doesn't
apply to Paige but I was going to ask
did any of you guys ever fantasize about
having like a long lost sibling
hey that could still happen yeah
um never thought about that really you
go no am I the only one yeah yeah I feel
like that would [__] up like the
beautiful magical balance of my life it
would be it would be cool like it
wouldn't I wouldn't be like
get out of here I'd be like okay but it
would be the seeing my because my
parents have been together no fans oh I
don't I don't give a [__] my parents
grow up or break up and I'm just kidding
we were pumped when they got divorced
yeah I was like that yeah yeah they're
they're still good friends that my
stepdad and Mom have birthday parties
for my dad they're all good way better
yeah it's cool and you got more like
more presents more fun three Christmases
but yeah I wonder how I would feel if um
there was a new girl that Bobby was
dating like really being loving towards
my cats you know what I mean and taking
pictures with my cats and posting it on
Instagram it would be annoying but you'd
get over it it happens to the best of us
it's gonna happen [__] did I give you
permission to touch my cats damn that
would be a weird one maybe but that's
when you have to like you have to like
get your ego out of it and just be happy
that he is finding someone that is
loving yeah because you wouldn't want
them to not like your cat you know it's
like it's just that like well he didn't
wasn't nice to me when I was being nice
to my cat like he's being nice to her
you know it'd be like that type of thing
probably yeah also
in general like this is sort of a thing
I'm trying to lean into is like there
will never be another person like me
there will always be someone prettier
there will always be someone younger
there will always be someone with bigger
boobs but there will never be someone
else like me and I feel like if you lean
into that and you're like oh they're
putting that person's petting my cats
well they're never gonna be me so go
ahead right yeah they're not getting
that same thumb print
that's true what if what if the girl got
your specific implants put in her body
Oh you mean okay because I got my
titties taken out now I don't have them
I'm fine
yeah she's gone into the closet the
kalila closet well they were supposed to
go to Theo Von he has asked to to own my
um to own them is there like body matter
on it can I get in on the fight there is
a cause I mean it is I should just not
enough yeah put them on eBay slap those
tits on eBay for sure I should huh they
were not great you do have two I have
two I told Theo I'd give him one can you
reuse them or what well let's suppose
you can let's suppose they've been
sterilized right and then she takes them
what would you do cut them out
and then Bobby's just fully enjoying
them yeah Bobby loves he can't he's
titty [__] and he he posts pictures
of them he's like oh I love these
there's something familiar about them
but better I'm doing better
you really are making my armpits there
is a like and you cut them out if you're
like those are mine because I know Chris
Hanson got in trouble for
for stealing license he did something
where he stole licensed thing and and
O.J Simpson his trophy that got sold he
went to jail for stealing it can you
once she has it in her body do you go to
jail for chopping it out wait what are
you doing like if those are my implants
those were not given to her they're
obviously mine they have a serial number
on it
damn easiest route probably just call
the cops and whatever slice first
uh because if you're wrong that's wrong
you probably wouldn't get in trouble you
probably would not get in trouble for
taking them but you probably get in
trouble for slicing her over the slice
it's the slice that'll get you in
trouble yeah
yeah you know what we should have you
around for more legal counsel you're
good at this thank you this is the two
of you none of us stand a chance I'm
going to be in prison for life double
life sentence well I'll be nice about it
I'll go through the nipples so like the
scarring wouldn't show a lot the nicest
way or no I have mine in my nipple and
you cannot see anything there's no AB
there's I have no scarring on my breasts
so do you have sensitivity in your
nipples still I have no feelings around
the area that like on the inside here I
don't know why but you could you could
basically stab me there and I wouldn't
feel anything it kind of sucks is that
even emotional like stabbing even now I
don't really have like sensation like
right on the what about on your nipple
the nipple I do oh that's interesting
that's what size of boobs did you have
double D's and I here's a [__] up part
I wanted C's I wanted full C's and I
woke up with double D's and he said well
I guess
um when he put the implants there
because I have far apart breasts and
what he said was the full Seas would not
give me like a true cleavage and he took
artistic Liberties and I remember waking
up and being like these are too big I
felt claustrophobic we need one doctor
to just do you good we just one
girl yeah
I'll send you guys titties they were
huge I um how long do you have them in
uh under two years wow because I was
like you never got used to them you
never hated it oh yeah hated them hated
the type of you didn't want that like
they gave you something you didn't want
do you think it would have gotten the
Seas you would still have them in
possibly possibly what did he say oh
just massage them they'll go down yeah
and he told me to massage them I think a
little bit too hard because if you're
telling an athlete to like you got to go
hard I think I went too hard I caused
like some internal like bleeding stuff
because one tit became so hard that it
stayed up here and the other stayed nice
and soft Mama's upset yeah that's that's
not good of him to do that were you like
that boy were you sleeping when you made
that decision I don't [__] know but
he's a you know he's a well-known
Beverly Hills doctor I obviously can't
say his name because he signed that away
too yeah yeah Chelsea you made the
mistake of letting me know that you have
like a motherly caregiving personality
so I'm just curious like
what kind of advice would you give to me
as someone who's like perpetually lonely
on the inside like maybe it would be
like a perfect day together that we what
would you me and you yeah oh my God are
you a do you like a physical like is
that weird
because I like this week
no I need that I need touch like I would
lay on the couch and like just like
because you're so tiny you would fit
right here just perfectly we could spoon
oh she's got like one of those holders
for her oh a little baby strap yes like
Dr Evil I'm definitely fantasizing about
that kind of video I'm serious and
you're so little and I love like you
know spooning people and not even a
weird I don't get weirded out I'll just
spoon people no totally but I think you
guys should walk around Venice but you
and a Baby Bjorn okay
yeah we're walking let's walking or a
stroller and I'll cook you dinner and
make your plate and I'll ask you did you
want mac and cheese you want another
scoop you want you guys like I'm
physical reactions right now just like
the way you're saying it and I'll be
like what do you want to drink I'll make
you a drink did you want a straw you
know I'll make sure you said
and and snuggled oh gosh that'd be great
dude and not even weird wait what city
do you live in no you'll have to come
see me in Nashville okay yes would you
want to wear a bath like a bubble she
loves baths
that's your rubber ducky all of your
toys
we could do it like it's for social
media but I
mean Paige page that's a good question
do you not let Dave do that for you he's
like not really he's over nurturing he's
it's just different like he would not
bathe me
David Dave does do a lot Dave does a lot
Dave will bring her her popcorn maybe
not seasoned correct that'll bring it he
does that but then it's like yeah I have
a lot of needs only one person is enough
can you need like a Todd because Todd
will there's not like an end to the
things he's doing so like he can bring
me something and then there's another
thing that could be brought and another
yeah then it's like [__] I'll just do it
myself yeah every once in a while he's
like
like I'm done and I'm like okay like
that's it no more from you yeah yeah
well you guys you Chelsea you and Annie
have a lot in common and I found this
out yesterday you guys are obsessed with
crab legs it's my number one favorite
thing king crab legs listen but I'll do
king too but King is sometimes too salty
for me whoa I know it's offensive okay
but I also think I can get so much more
and I feel like so much of the king crab
is like the weight of it is
the shell yes and you're and you are
right on that
um I love all crab leg I mean I will do
the Crab Claw I'll if crab claws are on
the menu I'm ordering them yes any any
crab king is my number one number one
obviously it's the king yes it is the
king
um oh God you know about the shortage
yes it's upsetting well oh yeah and if
if price is double oh no
money doesn't factor into this at all
okay over the pandemic in the beginning
I was still very I was struggling it was
in my struggling phase when I got my
check my trump check I was in the line
there was a line of people all of us had
our checks we were in line at Hot and
Juicy which is now rip hot and just he's
gone we would okay I know hot and juicy
closed down to like what has been your
alternative for crab legs you know I
just we just you go on Postmates there's
a couple near closer have you guys ever
been to like the um San Pedro
um Pierre
San Pedro myself you can just choose um
whatever seafood and you have them cook
it whatever way no where's it no in San
Pedro at the births
yeah but it's always where I go with my
family for seafood it's really fun but
yeah since hot and juicy hasn't gone
under but I was I wanted to ask you guys
about Casino buffets
um is there
um
is there a strategy that you have is
there a favorite casino buffet and is
there a strategy of how you attack a
buffet what's how do you open how do you
close it's crab legs and you open the
crab legs yes crab legs yes water no
carbonated beverage wait why oh because
it gets six of a broom okay no bread
I'm telling you I will do like one or
two things but I'm getting them just
kind of have look like I have a variety
but I'm going I'm I'm I would say 99.9
crab legs also sorry I know that this is
like not environmentally friendly or
whatever but I have a policy where
whenever I go back up I start with a new
plate I want to start over I want to
have a fresh sleeve oh I respect that oh
yeah I'm a fresh plate guy I like to
listen I'll get a fresh plate but I'll
leave that [__] on the table I want to
see my mess
I'm proud of my mess yeah it's a trophy
at a buffet like I want you to know I'm
getting my money's worth I'm getting it
all but I will I mean the piles of crab
legs yeah yeah and it's not like take a
few yeah I don't know and the prime rib
top two carving stations have yes but
carving stations are not an opener
um you kind of are like maybe
right in the middle yeah halfway what is
your favorite casino buffet
um well because I I did sold my country
growing up we went to so many in like
you know different parts of Illinois
where's Dad where'd Daddy go but I
haven't done any of the elite Vegas ones
because I think like I but maybe I went
to the win once with Dave but
um I just I do feel in my heart of
hearts that actually like all of us I
was gonna say this about us three but
you guys are included in this too
doesn't it feel like we all potentially
could have met each other at a casino
buffet like that's not all of these
friends
look at us I can see that yes yes it is
my happy place just walking into a
casino in general it's like I'm so happy
oh the smell oh everything's perfect I
love Vegas but I will say as a baby
I think we could really open those crab
legs for you have the meat ready for you
you don't like crab legs I've never had
them but do you think it's the chore
well the experience of having someone
actually get it out for you is really
something you have to catch them though
why catch a lobster I can't get crab
crabs a little bit deeper spiny Lobster
yeah I have a lobster yeah do you guys
cook them we're going on Three Rivers
yourself yes
um yeah if I go get my own Lobster I
I'll I'll cook them I will we will we'll
go jet lobsters and well boy there's a
way yeah yeah I like crab better but yes
I like lobster yeah yeah you gotta have
crab legs Honeys I know I'm not okay for
you okay
oh my God it's but you can you know the
type of girl that she's explaining it so
there's like a it's there's a lot of
work to do so maybe it needs to be well
I think I've just I the like touching
the little thing okay and there's a way
to do it there's a strategy there's a
way once you know what you're doing it's
nothing do you like activity foods like
sunflower seeds or like pistachios yeah
okay activity Foods crab legs are are
part of homework food yeah sometimes you
just don't get enough though like on
artichokes oh so annoying it's so good
and there's so little there I know I'm
getting stressed life hacked I started
just chewing my artichoke I was like you
know what I'm just gonna eat the bad
part I did last time I got artichoke I
was like ah [__] you artichoke I will
just crunch this I would stabbing you on
the way oh you're just bleeding I don't
[__] care see this is why I eliminate
all of that frustration I go to Trader
Joe's and I get their Grilled artichoke
and it's just all the hearts but grilled
and it has that same Joy of it's there's
nothing better
oh yeah because it's not quite an
activity you didn't like but just please
try to Trader Joe's like grilled
artichokes okay it is such a joy in the
Frozen yeah
it's an oil it's like yeah it's
saturated in oil it's delicious
I'll try it yes me too because I go by
the jar of artichokes put it in pasta
yep exactly good I would like I would
just I want like two your bun crab legs
right now
there's not just a pile of crab legs
right here or do you dip them are you a
butter guy oh I'm dipping my whole hand
yes everything's in the butter and
sometimes they put the garlic and it's
like look I'm not gonna be mad at you if
you do it but I just need regular butter
I'm fine with it same I'm with her I
mean we talked about the crab like
burpage
um I this is why like I like Boiling
Crab but I'm not obsessed with Boiling
Crab because I really do like the flavor
of just a seafood with butter and the
option for garlic and spice if I need it
yeah naked
with the butter
I love it that sounds good I am like I
love that damn we're not eating crab
legs oh my God I'm having like I'm
starting to get sweat we should have
just had a crab boil I know just filmed
it my on my auntie will make she calls
it the dump she puts like sausage crab
legs shrimp potatoes corn put some
spices and everything and then she just
dumps it on the table that's what we
that's it yeah the crab oil we do we do
it in my backyard all the time with my
best friend Corey and he does it so well
it's good to have friends that can cook
who's the best cook out of you three
it's got to be her because I've had her
food
there's a salt and sugar issue here oh
you get all mixed up honeys
I made her some vegan cookies in the
pandemic and I thought they were the
best cookies I've ever it was like I
thought it was like a joke I was like
are we kidding it's like gummy and dry
at the same time they were a really
unique consistency I think you just
accomplished making them you were so
excited
I cooked a lot in the pandemic but it
was very you know experimental yeah yeah
are you a good cook I am that's
something that I'm really proud of I
cook every day I also uh I cook every
day of my life what do you today I'm
making chicken tinola which is like kind
of like a soup it's with uh it's chicken
thighs with um the regular mirepoix
which is the a carrot celery and the
onions and then I add Ginger and cabbage
and it's just a very soothing kind of
cold weather meal that's what I'm making
like a chunk of like cooked
Ginger and something really Ginger is
everything it cuts through I love
everything but um lemongrassing oh I
cook a lot with sometimes I cook with
lemongrass but I cook a lot of Filipino
food yeah because it's like comforting
to me I love stews I'm a stew Queen is
that dish you just described a Filipino
dish uh a version of it it usually has
this other Leaf called malungai which is
like a small little baby leafy thing but
I I don't find it
um easily here and it has uh have you
guys heard of chayote
chayote is like a we call it sayote but
it's like a green kind of squash but
it's very soothing
I wish I could cook for you guys please
do yeah we'll we'll contribute dude next
time and you can make us a stew I would
love that I'm dead serious yeah we never
crab oil but yes but we gotta get we
gotta get the seafood from like the
Asian market okay yes yes yes go to San
Gabriel I'm gonna have Todd's mom take
me to a seafood market and get me the
the craziest thing I would trust Todd's
mom oh she's she's my favorite
restaurant she's everything how's Todd
doing he's the best I've never even met
him
on Valentine's Day he posted a very cute
thing I love my time
oh how do you guys meet he worked at The
Comedy Store he was in the basement I
said you're not supposed to be down here
and I plucked him and I said if you want
to meet my friends I have to not meet
yours
we've just ushered them up into life now
he's an Emmy Award winner oh hell wow
Netflix shows he works my solo podcast
anyone yeah he's the best he's spruced
up from that basement I knew I saw oh my
God I just got to get you out of here
get you up I didn't have to like I
didn't pitch him to anyone he just got
around people and they just smelled his
talent and you are yeah
I just saw it I was like I just need to
get them there and then I just couldn't
be Hands-On because it wouldn't have
made me in a basement I found you close
to the uh loitering around the basement
that's true actually is that right where
you met actually right like steps away
from where I'm at Todd and I said you're
supposed to be down there
you pushed me down by the way are those
stairs not the most falled downable
stairs at the comedy store which by the
way don't tell Paige for a couple days
if you want to come to The Comedy Store
I'll be there Wednesday either Wednesday
I'm there tonight I didn't go I don't
think oh because your boyfriend's out of
town yeah
I'm just like I wanted to go but then I
was like should we like
I don't know have anal or something
something yeah yeah yeah
um is anal still on the table for you
and Greg and for you and your boyfriend
six years in 16 years in
it's um like once every couple years
type of thing okay that makes it looks
like that's reasonable maybe if we
revisit this it'll be different yeah
still the same yeah but I'll do it yeah
I'll do it it's not off the table for
sure but it's not like the first thing
that pops into myself like it's
definitely has to be a for a special
event my buttholes must be tight or
something because it it's not it hurts
yeah you know yeah oh yeah yeah I don't
know that it's like a loose tight
butthole thing I think it's a ability to
relax the muscles but I don't have that
there's no relaxation I don't think my
brain like goes to my [__] there's no
way I can relax myself it feels like my
yeah it feels like my asshole's on its
own oh it's like on its own Island it
has its own brain its own thoughts yeah
and they're not different with mine and
they're not matched up you can take
poppers I heard
oh for real
this is a good look was it good what
happened I
just got really hot oh yeah you didn't
put anything in your butt at all no I
mean he's so full of [__] this is where
we find Carlos I would tell
you okay
right hi guys so this is for everyone
did it do something to your butt what is
whoa
no tingle in your butthole at all no
guys I've been jumping on a trampoline I
gotta tell you like all of your body you
get [__] up from it it feels good I
got a trampoline like one of those mini
trampolines and it was making me really
horny to bounce on it I think because
maybe like air was going inside I was
getting my hair [__] I was like oh my
God [__] lips were jiggling and
everything was like really they were
swinging up yeah smacking
the wind was they were back winded and
they were whipped before Oh my god I've
never felt that
maybe you guys could double bounce me
we'll get you through the room the moon
dude but it was like I was like is this
a thing I haven't looked it up will you
look up if bouncing makes you horny or
why it would bouncy makes you it should
it should it really was like a well my
I'm going to ralphing where this guy's
like doing this it's like a really deep
like it's a series of um massages where
they go and they're trying to like
figure out structurally what's going on
with your body and they go deep into the
fascia and like reset where your bones
are what's it called it's called raw
thing like roll on the floor laughing
and um crazy
exercising it was the specific bounce
well you know what it kind of is you
know when you're on a roller coaster you
get kind of horny right yeah it's like
that don't feel that on roller coasters
at all are you motion sick no I'm
terrified for my life I'm trying to
survive yeah
hi listen on my deathbed it will be wet
let's just say oh my God
I will be in the wet spot I love it I
love my boyfriend not Todd who we were
talking about Ty is uh my Todd he is
motion sick so he can't go on roller
coasters and it's so sweet me and Todd
could sit by ourselves when do you think
that I didn't immediately think that
when you're you were in my peripheral
and I was saying that but I was thinking
about that because I just it's so I just
love being scared but Todd likes he like
slash her he likes to be scared he just
can't do the motion not a physical he
can't do the first right wait that's
actually surprising because I I or no I
think there's like this um study that
says couples who I remember this yes if
they both it's better you're more
compatible if you both like horror or if
you both like like rides but I think it
is because he can't go it's not yeah he
has the personality of someone that
would like a ride yeah he just
physically is that he's like okay boy
I'm like yeah I can't believe I'm gonna
marry puke boy yeah yeah because growing
up you know you're married yeah we're
like re-engaged we have a room or we
have a ring but he has to get it put
together I've been pre-engaged with
every guy I've ever met well listen I
know Carlos
oh
you'd be lucky Carlos did you get able
to slap him across the room he was about
to get sent up to the Moon
um we're gonna double bounce you Carlos
if you ever say that again double bounce
are there things you guys find hot in
like weird things you find hot in men
that you think others would be like what
the [__]
maybe like like a physical thing
no
yes yeah it looks like he's been through
something but it was he was just born
with a cleft lip he came in fighting you
came in in a night fight let's go but I
feel like Joaquin Phoenix and the other
guy from Europe but Joaquin also has
that thing too from what
um um My Best Friend's Wedding from My
Best Friend's Wedding yeah Dermot
Mulroney yes yes him so My Best Friend's
Wedding kind of ruined my life do you
remember the movie vaguely I know I
remember the premise of the movie of the
movie is spoiler guys that came out in
1990 [__] sick Paige hates movies
yeah she's not a movie I don't hate them
I just cannot stay awake
I don't like don't ever talk to me like
that I love movies I love movies
yeah [__] are there any weird things
that you're just like wow I find that so
hot in a guy but maybe um maybe like not
quite the cleft palate thing but maybe
like if they take off a hat and like
it's like sweaty that that's kind of
attractive sometimes he's been working
in the field he's been he's been uh out
there on the tractor no no on the
tractor or maybe he's sweating because
his penis got stuck in the day
reminds her name or like chest I don't
know I like hair kinda yeah I like big
noses me too yeah very on Trend when
they have like that bump oh look at mine
even in in women yes that is ever since
I was a little girl I have been so I
thought that was so beautiful you want
to [__] my nose I would I'd let I'd rub
my [__] on it yeah all I wanted to get
and I didn't bring it in time I didn't
get it in time I wanted to get edible
underwear and see if I could make you
guys eat each other
[Music]
they could just watch come on I'd watch
I'd watch no I like I don't want to make
you uncomfortable Paige but I do things
really beautiful and it's like very
attractive thank you I told you that
everyone can have her I love a good
prominent nose I like thank you biggest
thing and Todd doesn't have like an
outward big nose but it's like it's like
wide and like round and it's so cute
wait what is the plot of my best friends
okay so the plot of my best friends that
ruined my life so it's it's these guy
and girlfriends growing up
and um they have gone separate ways
Julia Roberts and Derma Maroney and
Julia Roberts gets a call from Jeremiah
hey got to talk to you they're both
turning 30 I think I've got to talk to
you about something give me a call back
miss you love you whatever hangs up
she's talking to her gay friend she goes
oh I I have this friend and we had this
thing in college where like if we didn't
weren't married by 30 we would get
married and then she's like wait that's
why he's calling me like I'm not ready
to get married so she's like so nervous
about it so then she finally like calls
him back and it turns out he's like I
met the love of my life I'm getting
married to Cameron Diaz who's like
bubbly and like stupid and cute and so
now she's like wait you're not gonna
marry me then she gets so jealous and
then she's like pissed that he's
marrying this girl and then it's all
about like Letting Go the whole thing
and why did that ruin your life because
I was in that my whole my whole like
young adult life was me like pining over
one of my guy friends feeling like we
were gonna end up together and then they
like meet someone and then feeling like
never like getting it I mean I got over
that but you're not waiting for that
call oh God she found Todd yeah I know I
found my guy but also if any of them
called me I would say I got over that
about 10 years ago but yeah it was just
like I remember watch that movie and be
like this isn't my life oh I need to
re-watch it I know it sounds really good
I saw when it was so little that I don't
remember anything about it it's just a
little thank you another great rom-com
that is um one of my favorites is with
Cameron Diaz as well as the holiday oh
yeah that one's a really sweet one I
just love her yeah write that down okay
the best camera deals with me though
come on is the sweetest thing yes yes
that's like a crazy girl movie Yes with
Christina Applegate yeah and uh yeah
yeah couldn't she get she gets her
tongue ring stuck on a dick oh yeah yeah
what's something they did a couple years
ago
oh maybe that too oh I don't want to
bring it up but it is they have him two
out of three of them who
and I wish them well but Cameron you
better get yourself check [__] what the
hell is going on here
how did they get that
I don't know how that you delivered it
like a joke they both have MS
yeah I didn't even know that that
complete enough but it's like you're
right how did this happen maybe on time
or something
anyways yeah craft Services when was the
first time you discovered that you were
a fart artist and why do we have
tomatoes right next to you
well we familiarize because I yeah we
can do that too
um that type butthole let's see how
tight that bottle is yeah I guess we'll
figure out figure that one out uh at
what age were you like I think I can do
this and this is a life path well when
my sister is pregnant I think like five
years ago
I'm like you know what I need to fart
out the baby baby powder to like you
know everyone was doing the gender
reveals at that time huge you know oh my
God and I wanted to make a
make fun of it yeah so that's when I
farted the blue Powder out of my butt
yeah and I'm like I have to do this
before nobody else nobody else probably
even thinking about it right you're
right but that's when I first did it and
once you do something you know people
latch on now I can't even do anything
with where's the fort
why are you tired wait wait are you
tired of farting then are you are you
are you at a good point in your life
you're like you know what like I don't
want to fart anymore
no because I I'm gonna try to make some
money off of it well the girl who was
selling her farts she almost died oh
that that was the girl from um from a
reality show she was farting in jars and
she almost died it was a 90-day fiance
one the girl who went to Australia
um but she started uh monetizing her
farts and I think her diet consisted of
just really gaseous foods like onions
and beans for breakfast well that might
be a bubble that never pops yeah that
could be me wow Tomatoes make me fart
but I don't know if anyone else is doing
fart art the way you are yeah yeah
they're farting in jars but you found a
way to really make it artsy there really
is something very Maria Abramovich about
you you really are this like performance
artist the way you fall isn't just like
oh wait there is is there a cancer
cluster okay no I think that like there
are people where you can watch videos
and be like all right like they your
full commitment you throw your body into
situations like I've watched it starts
I've grown up like watching jackass and
those guys kind of don't have anything
on you they need to do better they do
need to do better and I cannot believe
they didn't pick you to be on on the on
that last movie I'm like you guys were
you in the running did you even know
what's happening
uh a little because I talked to Stevo's
manager sometimes but like I think they
maybe wanted me to go do something with
what's his name Zach ass yeah but it
wasn't like falling I think it was maybe
going down Escape like a 50-foot
skateboard ramp which I'm not a skater
yeah so not very smart for me to just
okay sure but you didn't really have a
whole lot of yeah let me go bash my face
for this but you don't have a whole lot
of like fear around like being
physically hurt because you've launched
your body because with the Falls I don't
get really just like a couple bruises
you know on the knees but other than
that I'm good do you fall like do you
have like a little technique yeah yeah
definitely a technique arms first it's
my legs first like for as long as my
um hips and stuff hit the ground then
it's like and do you look back at your
tapes and you're like that was a good
fall that wasn't a good fall and what's
been your favorite fall yeah definitely
um yeah definitely all the segments
Legends of the Fall the in and out fall
was probably have you seen that one
probably there no can we pull up the in
and out fall I love that's Bobby's
favorite ones I never think like yeah
it's on Instagram I did used to do Pratt
Falls I did a bet with this guy at the
comedy store where we had to do this was
like four or five years ago we had to do
could be eight who knows
um we had to do three Pratt Falls in one
week coming onto the stage of The Comedy
Store and we could not acknowledge that
we did it on purpose so you would just
bomb for 15 minutes afterwards but I
never did it like I never got hurt hurt
but I had no method and it was like a
matter of time but I was able and I
would always bring Cup on for a fact I'd
have a cup of water and trip and get it
on in front of me and you can't warn the
person before you either that's the
thing like the things you're holding is
what makes them and the sound
definitely wait I actually can't see
because the camera
oh
yeah that's so good pig you gotta get a
full a full tray of things and then have
your hair out whipping yeah wait that is
like as a person who's a trained dancer
like that is beautiful choreography but
you should just go through all of her
Falls and I'm telling you it's Artful it
is no that's not that's [__] skill
and now how long after are you holding
the I just fell the whole time I I just
go to oh my gosh I'm so embarrassed I'm
so embarrassed and people are like
tampons this is so numbers I dropped all
my tampons yeah I'm just gaslighting
them so I don't get kicked out wait this
is you and Chelsea's listen where is
this oh you guys friends Master Yeah we
actually did something with him but love
never got to see it I think it'd be cool
to do the fall and then like everyone
saw and then like ask someone on a date
like do some most and make it even worse
will you [__] me
if no one tries to help her up she'll
literally just go be like hold up her
hands like and they'll come over and
help her that's what I know this yeah
I'm definitely afraid to like go like ah
because yeah if you put people in
distress then
they're taking it down
whack so I just have to silently fall
and she'll come up and we do a whole
thing where she'll hold a Starbucks and
then or a Big Gulp and then she'll be
like you almost made me spill my big
gulp this is 287. and people be like oh
my gosh and she's like I'll beat your
ass too we need to do another one it's
been a while yeah yeah this old lady
yell at me once on on that video in
Ocean Beach in San Diego because I was
like kicking her where she fell she fell
into me and they don't know we know each
other and that we're you know and so I
was kicking her and this lady this old
lady just got so mad at me like what I I
even like was like [__] you lady or
something I don't know
it's fun dude it's fun to get in public
yeah
and this is very tame but we were just
we just knew that we had this agreement
that we may get in a fake fight at any
point any time in public so we'd just be
like at Home Depot and everything would
be fine and be like [__] you and it'd be
like we just create like we would
improvise whatever the fight was going
to be about like my grandmother was
dying you said I couldn't go she's
[__] dead she's dead you know we
didn't have cell phones or anything
really that's the best though that's fun
those memories beg my friends I'd be
like let's do a fake fight it would be
in the cafeteria come on let's do it and
nowhere to do it leave I was I've just
got in a real fight with him
Esther you're being a [__] about this
type thing
I love that [__] I want to do pranks
with you guys I'll follow oh dude okay
I'd love to do [__] with you guys let's
do it let's plan for that I'm like
trying to get more like because I have
it in me to be pranky but then there's
this like little part of me you know I
know that you battled this like they'll
probably be like
like oh are people gonna get like upset
and then you have to like push through
that and once you push there's always
the funniest thing it's just gotta look
real and they they can't know that
you're filming and you want to do it
yeah you want to like there's that
instinct for me at least to be like it's
fake you know but then you're like
we never tell people that we're nothing
yeah ever because if you say it's fake
they're like okay well we need you to
sign this dude no it's all real and
you're getting the hell out of it yeah I
wish I had stayed with this but I I gave
in but I I had um this guy Damien Leone
who did terrifier too which is this like
movie I'm obsessed with he does the
slasher slasher makeup and stuff so I
had him do all the effects on my face
like where my face was all cut up and it
was for my podcast but then I had a spot
that night and I didn't want to take the
makeup off so I was like
I was like I'll just go to The Comedy
Store with it on so I have my face like
all sliced up on stage and I made it I
pretended that uh Leslie Jones had beat
me up beforehand ahead of me but I only
let that go for like a minute because
everyone was so worried about me they
did look really real I saw your story
and I was like if I know Annie at all I
know this is another thing I wasn't
Smiley
but then I go on stage and then I like
reveal and then there's a guy in the
front row whose face is sliced up well
he had gotten hit by a car the week
before I was like what are the [__]
chances that you're sitting right here
right now and his face was just it was
so crazy hit by a car I did no I'm 100
dead yeah like that's too crazy it
always happens like that hey guy got hit
by a car and still showed up yeah yeah
that's how much he loves comedy big fan
I know
I was like ew did you come for me I saw
somebody get hit by a car in L.A really
did they live she had two masks on
that's how much she wanted to live and
got hit by a car
you know cars have those bras yes car
masks that had two on two like oh my God
it's probably gonna cured her her line
of vision because it was probably so
high up here and she didn't have like
peripherals the car ran the a red light
oh the car hit her and bounced back and
she's just laying there and I I don't
think people really wanted to to touch
it was like we're filming yeah everyone
started going up to her like that well
it's kind of tricky when you go like
when it's like a someone who could have
broken their neck yeah you don't want to
move them so like and especially if
you're somebody like if you're a regular
citizen trying to help you're protected
but if you're someone who's a nurse yeah
and you [__] something up then you could
be in trouble so you there's always that
one psycho that's like give me a big pen
right so like my sister so if someone's
on the plane in like medical like in
need of anything medical my sister is
not being like help she always is just
like if they call and then no one else
stands up then I'll go but there's
always like a illegal yeah
that's good to know so if I'm ever in a
situation I'm gonna be like who's the
nurse who's hiding they could have at
least like popped off one mask for some
breathing maybe her masks stay on stayed
on Wow
and did we do we know the outcome
I I it wasn't looking good when I saw
when I saw the car bounce back you know
that's not car bounced back that's when
you know
was she big
an older shorter bigger lady yeah that
woman's dead she's passed oh rip yeah
God bless well Paige
um I am looking at those tomatoes and
tomatoes make me [__] blood they really
do is the one food I can't have like
tomato sauce on anything yeah because I
just straight up [__] blood they're
nightshades I don't like Nightshade I
love the taste I don't think it matters
whether you like them I don't think they
like you I don't think they like me
I'm looking at them and I don't want you
to eat them because I don't want you to
be gassy and uncomfortable
I want you to be farting to fart and oh
she's been eating on them oh you have
been eating haven't you yeah eating on
this is so funny
I could probably find it I have to leave
early okay I'm gonna head out yeah yeah
I just gotta go eat on her day oh
masturbate to this conversation and
you're taking donut yeah oh sorry that's
okay they only have each other can I
hold her real quick before you leave
were you gonna try to fart though
um are we farting or what telling you
right now Paige if I eat that it's not
fart that's gonna come out it's gonna be
pure red squirting onto canvas do you
need to fart page I could definitely try
right now I think at least give it a go
we gotta give it a go after all this
chat yeah yeah yeah yeah and if there's
anything I can do to help you like
assist you in any way like I'm game okay
I'll let you know for sure sometimes
yeah and sometimes we'll be here for 30
minutes operating um wait sit back no I
think it's coming for real okay but I
will say I did not take a doo-doo before
the sofa it smells like straight doodoo
oh that's fine a poop fart yeah yeah oh
those not good you know Esther for for
someone who says she loves human smells
I really feel like she would have really
she bounced dude we can bottle it up
we're getting us to around the corpse
because I'm calling that bluff around a
court there's not a [__] chance
should be chill around a corpse uh on
her birthday
take blindfolder like you're gonna take
or something I have a great surprise for
your your biggest wish and then leave
her at the there's heaven or a cold more
yeah lever but we should rig it to just
to [__] with her where there's like
something poking into the hands oh my
God she wouldn't forget Esther seems
game for a surprise this girl her
friends wouldn't have that fake fight
with her because if you surprise us
you'll have three years off of Esther oh
Hobby Lobby I guess Pink by the way that
is the greatest gender reveal I have
that instinct too always like when
there's the popular thing people are
doing you're like what how can I make
fun yeah yeah
the powder you get from Party City yeah
yes you know what they mean to sponsor
me wait can I just see the ingredients I
hope this is it's definitely not it's
not what it's meant I'll be in a balloon
talcum powder cow come here
I was like damn eat on that damn eat on
that I'll tell you what's not good about
it so it's not it doesn't have calcum
powder but it does have red dye oh oh
yeah that's consuming red dots and Tacos
good for you red 40 is my you're right
Orange
oh yeah am I tripping or where's the the
oh I brought a canvas stuff but I have
to hurry up and paint the canvas and
then I think I'm pretty much good for a
good fart oh should I go wipe my
butthole no no who cares who cares Paige
should I pack the powder you want one of
them to do it yes ma'am I could pack
your powder page if you want I know
Astra always leaves on the gay Parts huh
but tell me Chelsea can you show me how
to pack powder yeah really I feel like
you're passing
well I don't want him to get demonetized
well blur okay
yeah yeah I think so Esther's Mike yeah
she missed it out okay that's how you
pack it you pack it you kind of open it
a little bit okay you gotta open the
cheeks a little
that's it that was it bro oh my hand got
warm
[Laughter]
dope bro that was it wow
no no no you're good Hearts were amazing
yeah maybe I didn't put enough
hodgepodge on do we think we'll see well
look it's there's some pink on there and
I think that's enough the smell of the
fart with the uh yeah this is art
piece [__] Splat paint on a thing the
the smell of that fart with the um sorry
no with the thing together it's funny oh
the it's like yeah
[Laughter]
oh water was saying thank you everybody
for being here
supporting trash Tuesday they are
wonderful women
they really are
Paige I just want to say before we wrap
this up and Chelsea that I haven't been
I know that people get into these like
Circle Jerks and do these bonding things
so then get to know people that way this
couldn't have been a more bonding
experience for me
and I feel so much closer to you guys
and I feel like we're family now and I
really have such a deep love for the
both of you so thank you for doing this
thank you for your oh [__]
thank you for
um thank you for your contribution to
the art world I think there are a lot of
pretentious art Bros out in the world
right now a lot of pretentious artists
who are nepo babies who are putting you
know stuff that I'm like what are you
guys even doing this to me is real
performance art and I'm so glad you
exist and thank you guys so much for
watching another episode of trash
Tuesday we hope you enjoy this because
we sure did and we'll see you next week
thank you
[Music]
foreign